hallo ich bin's ali neu bei box kelly
bag nicht zaubern sonntag einfach
setting up dreißigsten september
[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt wir
waren dieses jahr im freizeitpark
efteling und ella und samira und auch
ich wie schwer man immer noch davon
da packt besuch war wirklich richtig
genial und eines unserer highlights war
auf jeden fall der krankenstand von
polle da haben nämlich richtig leckere
pfannkuchen gegessen und auch mit
zubereitet und ich habe ihr versprochen
dass wir die pfannkuchen mal für euch
nach machen werden und heute ist es
soweit heute gibt es ein basic video zum
pfannkuchenteig den könnt ihr wirklich
immer zu bereiten da gelingt immer und
die pfannkuchen schmecken wirklich
phänomenal lecker ich zeige euch mal
kurz die zutaten für den pfannkuchenteig
verwende ich nämlich vier eier zwei
teelöffel salz 500 gramm mehl und davon
die hälfte dinkel und weizenmehl und ein
liter milch und die zubereitung ist auch
ganz einfach ihr nehmt jetzt einfach mal
die eier in eine rührschüssel dann
machen wir direkt sei es dazu und jetzt
auch schon ein bisschen was vom mehl und
schön klümpchen frei rühren
da ist einfach nur wichtig dass am
anfang die eier mit dem mädel verrührt
werden und später die milch dann langsam
dazu kommt dann bekommt ihr wirklich
keine klümpchen im teig und ihr könnt
jetzt auch entweder so wie ich denke und
weiter nehmen oder in den beizen und
buchweizen das geht auch ganz gut wenn
ihr jetzt merkt der teig wird immer
fester dann nach und nach dem mich dazu
geben
[Musik]
das habe ich einen richtig schönen
glatten teig und jetzt ist ganz wichtig
dass er abgedeckt wird und 30 minuten
ruhen darf pfannkuchenteig könnt ihr
auch immer wunderbar morgens zubereiten
abdecken und im kühlschrank ruhen lassen
und dann am abend oder am nächsten tag
einfach die pfannkuchen zu bereiten
[Musik]
jetzt ist der pfannkuchenteig soweit und
ich muss ihn jetzt immer noch
durchführen
[Musik]
jetzt könnt ihr die pfannkuchen entweder
in einer eisen vom auspacken da habe ich
eine ganz spezielle crêpes pfanne oder
nehmt einfach eine beschichtete pfanne
und dann ein bisschen backt raumspray
volle macht auch gerne mal mit butter
kutter könnt ihr auch verwenden vor
allem für den besonderen geschmack aber
begrenzt da können das ein bisschen
einfacher portionieren und vor allem hat
er dann nur ganz wenig fett jetzt habe
ich die pfanne auf mittel hohe hitze
erwärmt und nehme jetzt einfach eine
schöpfkelle und dann müsste einfach mal
schauen also ich merke mir dann immer
ungefähr wie weit ich die geschäfte
gefüllt habe für die perfekte frank
kuchen und dann kommt es hier an den
rand und dann durch eine schwenkbewegung
einfach in die pfanne verteilen jetzt
kann man den pfannkuchen von beiden
seiten auspacken
[Musik]
hätte ich hier unsere pfannkuchen aus
gebacken und jetzt gibt es noch die süße
variante die haben wir auch beim polle
gegessen und zwar mit apfel
dafür nehme ich jetzt ein bisschen
butter also ein bisschen zwecks des
geschmacks dann etwas zucker
karamellisiert es so ein bisschen die
pfannkuchen habe ich mir als teenie und
als kind auch immer selber braucht in
der küche dann die apfelscheiben ich
habe jetzt die äpfel einfach in der
mitte entfernt und dann in ganz dünnen
scheiben gehoben
sonst kann man diese überlappen und hier
drauf geben wenn jetzt so ein bisschen
karamellisieren lassen und dann da
direkt in pfannkuchenteig darüber geben
und dann kann der auch von beiden seiten
ausgebacken werden
und die nicht so schönen april ringen
die könnt ihr dann einfach sondern es
[Musik]
kommt der kommt
ich habe ich jetzt den apfelpfannkuchen
des richtig schön karamellisierte den
probieren wir gleich jetzt geht es aber
erstmal zum herzhaften kuchen beim pole
habe ich nämlich eine mit lachs gegessen
der war richtig gut und zwar für rühre
ich jetzt dafür hier frischkäse mit
schmand da könnt ihr auch quark zum
beispiel nehmen oder das passiert da
habt ihr es geht auch immer ganz gut
oder saure sahne zum verfeinern mehr
richtig die habe ich jetzt aus unklar es
könnte aber auch natürlich zur stützung
geben
es bringt also meine besondere schärfe
mit rein dann etwas schnittlauch und
bisschen was hab ich auch das salz und
pfeffer und jetzt nicht zu viel salz bei
der lachs sowie sie auch gut gesalzen
ist jetzt zum anrichten nehme ich dann
immer gerne gabel und dann einfach ein
stechen
dann ein bisschen meerrettich frischkäse
[Musik]
und hier habe ich noch geräucherten
lachs
[Musik]
und da passt jetzt noch perfekt rucola
dazu und dann könnt ihr den pfannkuchen
schon beim voll da waren sie echt
riesengroß also ich glaube durchmesser
30 cm bei uns machen othello groß
[Musik]
und die pfannkuchen könnt ihr jetzt
servieren wie ihr möchtet gerne auch mit
nutella zum beispiel oder mit marmelade
ich mag es auch ganz gerne mit
schafskäse oder auch mit verschiedenen
soßen und füllungen
falls ihr mal sehen wollt was ich für
füllungen mache dann schreibt gerne in
die kommentare
dann machen wir gerne mal nach fleisch
füllung oder auch eine vegetarische
füllung und dann können dann richtig
schön im pfannkuchen abend machen
bei uns gibt es die oft auch zum
frühstück weil sie eben auch so schnell
gehen ich wünsche euch jetzt viel spaß
mit diesem grundrezept macht daraus was
ihr möchtet aber probiert gerne mal die
lachs variante und die abwehrvariante
aus schmeckt mir nicht besonders gut
also viel spaß beim nachbacken und
wieder bis zum nächsten mal
danke fürs rezept rolle
[Musik]
neu bei vox jetzt ist im wald und essen
einfach außergewöhnlich
die neue wachsen einfach dreißigsten
september
[Musik]